[audience laughs]
[clock button clicking]
Susan Polgar: If you
zoom in, you can see that
in the corner there on
her right-hand side,
it's a dark square,
so that's when the board
is turned the wrong way.
Hi, I'm Susan Polgar.
I have won four World Chess Championships
as well as five Olympic gold medals,
and I have broken the
gender barrier in chess.
Today, we are going to look at
some video segments from movies
where chess has been an important part.
[audience applauds]
Actually, this game that they are playing
is based on a real game
that was played by two grandmasters
who happen to be close friends of mine,
the Ukrainian Vassily Ivanchuk
and the American Patrick Wolff.
They played this game up
to this point back in 1993.
The fiction started in the
movie from a certain position,
in a few moves that went
in a different direction.
The actual game ended in a draw
between those two grandmasters
in, I think, 72 moves.
The game is having a break.
It's called "adjourned."
Even in those days, it actually
gave an unfair advantage
to the side who had better
coaches or friends or helpers
to do the analysis of
that adjourned position.
That option is no longer existing today.
In real life, opponents don't usually
stare at each other this much
or look at each other.
To some degree they look a little bit,
but they are just usually more busy
in trying to figure out the
best moves and calculations.
Chess players, some look
at the ceiling, some don't.
But regardless, that's pretty much
what is happening when
we calculate a variation.
We see the pieces moving.
Even though we have a
certain specific position
right in front of us, we need to foresee
when the pieces move
one, two, three, five,
10, 20 moves ahead sometimes.
In reality, some grandmasters do that,
that they look away from the actual board,
look at the ceiling or somewhere,
just really almost in
a way that the position
that is physically
actually in front of them
on the chessboard.
She sacrificed the queen,
which is very unusual,
because it's the most valuable
piece we have in chess.
So, she got her queen back,
because when a pawn
reaches all the way across,
it can promote any piece,
including the queen.
And so now she has a
major material advantage
at this point in the game.
The only thing she needs to worry about
that if Borgov starts giving checks.
And she blocked the check,
the checkmates, an attack on the king.
And now the black queen again
is attacking the white king.
And now she finally found
a square for her king
when there are no more dangerous checks.
And, therefore, white's material
advantage is overwhelming,
and I think we'll see the
end of the game right here.
[audience applauds]
You know, I was a pioneer
in a man's world of chess,
and I didn't have such nice treatment.
I was invited to a major elite tournament
in Spain back in 1987,
and one of the top players in the world
at the time who was one
of the participants,
he objected that, "What are women doing
in such a prestigious, elite tournament?
Women shouldn't be invited."
And another six-time US champion
that I played actually a year earlier
swiped the pieces off the board.
So this is kind of a little bit of
a idealistic world and not the reality,
not in the '70s or '80s or '90s,
when I was actively playing,
and I think even less
so in the '50s or '60s.
[chess pieces clacking]
[clock button clicking]
So, they're playing
reasonable starting moves
and normal opening moves.
So, a good clock player
could do it, as well.
Three games is a lot playing with a clock.
I think they are playing five minutes,
which is a traditional blitz game,
five minutes for the entire game.
Playing without the clock,
I have played actually
326 games simultaneously,
which was a world record at the time.
So, three is not so much compared to that.
[peppy music]
[chess pieces clacking]
[clock button clicks]
We're not seeing half of the chessboard
and the actual moves
to tell whether they are or not.
When it comes to the moves,
they are all definitely
possible positions,
and there's nothing illegal.
[peppy music]
She was tipping over her opponents' kings
in I think a few occasions.
That's not something
that anybody would do.
Additionally, historically,
tipping over the king
used to be the sign of resigning the game.
I definitely give thumbs up.
I really like this series,
'cause it did really give
a huge boost for chess
in general in the mainstream.
[suspenseful music]
[clock ticking]
I actually really like this scene.
It was one of my favorites, I think,
and the position was very visible.
You could see all the pieces.
Attendant: Takes bishop.
[clock ticking]
Susan: I remember when I was in Moscow
and I've seen a tournament
when I was still, like, 11, 12 years old.
They were moving those big pieces
on those big demonstration boards.
And now we can view games
live through the internet,
but back in the days, it was like this,
that they had those so-called
demonstration boards
to relay the actual
moves to larger crowds.
There is a very special
thing ongoing on the board
with this very last move
that we see right now,
with the knight capturing the bishop.
Attendant: King to rook two.
[clock ticking]
[chess piece clacks]
Susan: It is a winning position,
because now the black
king is under attack,
it's in check,
and then the upcoming
moves that will follow up
would lead to either major
material gain for white
or checkmate.
So, one of the things that
a lot of beginner players
or non-chess players don't understand
that why people resign until
the checkmate comes, right?
And at the same time, it's
between experienced players,
it's very normal that
they don't play the game
all the way out.
When they see that checkmate is coming
in two, three, four, five
moves, or even more than that,
or they lose their queen,
which is one of the most
important pieces, you know,
they would give the respect
to the opponent that,
"OK, I know what's coming."
MacAdams: My congratulations,
sir. A brilliant coup.
Susan: Applauding is not so much
part of the chess scene.
It could be because the game itself
was so aesthetically pleasing,
it's just something unusual.
You did something funny
or tricky, or, you know,
and that's what happened
a little bit here.
So they were enjoying it as
an art, as a performance.
Chess-wise, it was also one of the best.
I definitely would give a 10.
Ron: You there, d5!
[stone rolling]
[dramatic music]
[blades unsheathe]
[stone crumbles]
Susan: So, those were really
normal starting moves.
It's called the center counter
or the Scandinavian defense.
[stone exploding]
But then I think they were
more focused on the visuals
of pieces getting captured and eliminated.
The first three moves actually
that they did play on the board,
they are very clear and very realistic.
They didn't show even the whole board,
and it's very hard to make out
what's going on after that.
Tobey's a great actor and everything,
but just the pure fact
that he's just so much smaller in size
than his opponent here, Spassky.
The real Bobby Fischer,
who has been a friend
of mine and I knew well,
is a very tall, big guy
and humongous hands.
Commentator: Fischer has abandoned
his trademark Sicilian opening.
Susan: Talk about Fischer
abandoning his favorite
Sicilian opening --
the Sicilian is not white's choice.
I mean, Bobby Fischer used to be known
to start almost all his games
with his king pawn to e4,
and then moving the pawn up two squares
in front of his king.
That allows the Sicilian,
but Sicilian is a choice of black,
not of white.
So that's a little bit
inaccurate, I would say,
when it comes to phrasing it that way,
that he "abandoned the Sicilian."
He abandoned allowing the Sicilian,
but he didn't abandon the Sicilian.
[dramatic music]
[clock button clicks]
Bobby used to be known
to play an e4 player,
which means starting the game
with moving the pawn up
in front of his king.
And in this game that's
being shown in this segment
as well as in the real
game six of the match,
Fischer started with c4,
moving the pawn in front
of his queen-side bishop.
And that's the first
time he'd ever done that.
And that actually is really important,
because the element of surprise
is quite important in chess,
and that's what he was
shooting for in this game.
And, actually, I learned from it,
and when I played my world championship
against the Chinese champion Xie Jun,
I also did that similar trick
in that I was known to
usually start with d4,
with the pawn in front of my queen.
And that helped me win my last,
fourth world championship.
I also started with a different move,
moving my pawn in front of my king.
[Spassky applauds]
So, this is very unusual,
that somebody would smile and be so nice.
But I know Boris Spassky,
he's been a friend of
mine for many, many years,
and, actually,
that's what he did at
the actual championship.
But it's very, very uncommon.
Usually people are closer to crying
and holding their tears back than smiling.
Announcer: This is the final round
of our Rwabushenyi National
Chess Championship.
Phiona Mutesi and Christine Namaganda
are tied for first position
in the women's category.
They will now play the
final deciding game.
Susan: Everything is correct.
We can see the first few moves.
That's the queen's gambit, coincidentally,
where black has a choice
to accept the gambit.
That would mean to capture the pawn on c4
or play the declined.
You see the focus and the
concentration of the players here.
Phiona, who is actually a real person.
Katende: You belong here!
Administrator: Silent.
Susan: You're not supposed to
just speak loudly and disturb
the concentration of the players.
Well, once in a while it happens,
but it's very, very rare,
and usually that person is being
escorted out immediately
when that may happen.
I mean, there has been
some extreme situation
when somebody got really sick or even died
during the chess tournament.
But other than that, it's just not normal
that people would speak.
[dramatic music]
[clock button clicks]
I managed to figure
out the exact positions
and then what was going on.
So I would definitely
give a very high mark
for the technical
expertise of the directors
and the chess advisors here,
because they did a good job
in very realistically showing
the actual chess positions.
[chess pieces clacking]
[clock button clicking]
And as you can see,
the pawn got all the way to the other end.
And you can see that whole sequence,
that they make a move,
they press the clock,
they write the move down.
So that's also very correct.
I would give this segment definitely a 10.
Magneto: That foolish
law, or one just like it,
and come for you?
Susan: Not as practical
to see through the board
to differentiate even the colors,
which one is the white,
which one is the black,
but it's obviously visually very pleasing.
Magneto: And your children?
[dramatic music]
[chess piece clacks]
Charles: It does indeed.
Susan: There, I mean,
here they can trash-talk
or psych each other out,
which obviously is normal in casual games
or coffeehouse chess or in parks
but would not be a part
of competition chess.
We may play somebody
we don't like as much,
or they don't like us.
It's kind of life.
And, yeah, sometimes, they
have or they've tried to
psych you out and, you
know, get into your head,
like, stare at you or bang a piece,
make a move with a very loud movement,
or something like that, or, you know.
That, it's called bad sportsmanship.
Magneto: What do you do
when you wake up to that?
Susan: So, psychology
can be very important.
And it starts out right
from the very beginning.
Because in the beginning of the game,
there are many starting options,
and people have their favorite
options to start the game.
And it's a little psychological board
ongoing right from the
first move, whether,
whose preparation will
be actually on the board?
Who will walk into the other side's prep?
Let's say they both
prepared for the same thing.
Who got deeper into it?
So that's a real interesting
psychological game
right from the beginning.
And then, let's say they got out of that
and nobody got the significant advantage,
then later in the game, it's about,
how do you feel about your position?
In any of these movies and segments
is that they intentionally or not
don't show enough of the chess moves,
unlike in "Queen's Gambit."
[audience laughs]
[clock button clicking]
You can clearly see something is wrong.
If you zoom in, you can see that
in the corner there on
her right-hand side,
it's a dark square.
So that's when the board
is turned the wrong way,
which is a very typical
mistake, by the way.
There are so many commercials
and some movie scenes
when they don't pay
attention to that detail.
But also, the pieces are kind of
really random on the board, as well.
So this is the one that is thumbs down
when it comes to the chess-technical part.